hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend joined as always by my my good
pals Sonam Obsession uh my assistant now
for how many years four 14 and like a
half okay like yeah 14 and a half and
for how many of those years did you do
you think you really tried be honest I'm
gonna you want me to be honest yeah two
okay
and of course Matt Corley you always
give 100 oh of what you're capable of oh
right yeah about 10 of most people yes
yeah if you're you give 100 of the 10
that you're able to give what's your
name again my name is Cronin okay
it's nice to be here all together isn't
it it
is yeah do you like it do you like
coming in to see me and I'm not gonna
lie it's nice to like just kind of get
away drive here well you live in a mad
house I think it's fair to say why would
you no no I'm not putting you down
any mom who has twin two-year-old boys
who have figured out how to make weapons
yeah uh would probably say that it's
nice to come into a podcast it
absolutely is to come into two other
though I it does feel like I'm
going well are you saying my children
are out wait you just said
her kids are not don't you play
All Things no I'm sorry but that's not
cool no you're right I apologize I am
going from two toddlers to two other
kind of that's what I meant yeah two
toddlers to two toddlers is what
I meant yeah and so how's your little
I'm sorry I thought we were
into
children she's really into something
called pissy water which is uh just
seltzer water which she tries to call
spicy water but comes out pissy Wawa so
she all day is going pit baby PC Wawa
baby pissy Wawa right yeah child service
is gonna hear that yeah and they're
gonna think she has to drink her urine
so that's there's some kind of weird
stuff going on here it's good for you
yeah
it is
sea water no no you lost I know no
that's I thought that I was saying pissy
water like Glenn says it but you meant
piss is good for you have I'm not gonna
drink my piss you're not let's all drink
our piss right now uh sure okay just did
and yo it's fine
it's a good thing it's a podcast and
there's no video ah there's video on you
on YouTube
or wherever you enjoy your videos see
what I did there what are you doing room
for oh just in case they invent another
in case they invent another format I
just make sure that I always cover my
bases okay okay I'm very smart they
invented there are I was saying stuff
like this on the TV show back in the 90s
I was saying well you know I hope you
enjoy this either tonight or when you
see it in a rerun or someday when they
invent the internet I never said this I
said that in 94. okay there's actual
tape of it that was then destroyed
sometimes I'm I feel like you don't even
know that the internet exists now I'm
told it's amazing
it sure has got its pluses and minuses
okay
um no I'm very happy I like coming in
here because no one wants to see me
around my house they're quite happy for
me to leave oh yeah
I hear a lot of it's funny I hear a
Mexican band playing oh the minute I
leave I mean grass section
and uh and and it's weird because
there's no band there but the minute I
leave and then I see catering trucks
pulling up and I see lots of guests
showing up and everyone looks excited
it's that song where the Ewoks play when
they beat the Death Star just that whole
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
okay imagine you're looking at a scale
with everything you do for others on one
side and then on the other side of the
scale is everything you do for yourself
the question is is it balanced I think
in a lot of cases that's probably not
the situation well guess what therapy
can help you clarify your values find
more balance in your life so you can
keep being a rock star for others
without forgetting yourself in the
process to be honest I've never been a
rock star for anybody
but I get the idea so if you're thinking
of starting therapy I think you've
better help but try here's the cool
thing it's entirely online it's designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule so what you do is you fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge and I think one of the barriers
to getting therapy for a lot of people
is
I don't know I gotta go in I gotta sit
there with this person it's going to be
awkward what if it's not a good fit
I'm gonna feel weird saying this doesn't
work for me and not coming back all of
that's eliminated uh with better help so
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com Conan today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Conan I have a
question for you that you can answer so
Star Wars related yes about what you
just uh brought up okay which is I
remembered showing my son those movies
and he was you know uh enthralled and I
showed them to him when he was a little
boy he was like I don't know maybe he
was six or seven and I showed him those
movies and it was a big deal and then we
got to the one where I remembered the
Ewoks
doing a dance and singing a song called
like jab jab or something or glub club
and I said oh wait do you see this this
part man I said this part I remembered
seeing this in a theater and this is a
little rough but take a look
and we got to that part and it didn't
happen yeah what happened did they edit
it out in 1997 Lucas released special
editions of all three original films and
they did they added CG and then in Jedi
they took out the song that they sing
written by John Williams son which is
like a disco song called lopty neck and
they replace it with like a blue song
and then they took out that Ewok
celebration song and just put in this
somber yes like funeral dirge right so I
looked like a fool because I told my son
check this out it's really hilarious
because it doesn't quite work where do
you see this and then it didn't happen
what was the song how did it go
and then of course they've got the
curtain call with old Darth Vader
they're dead but then they switched it
with young Hayden Christensen yeah yeah
um yeah you want me to keep going on are
you about to say something can you no no
I was just remembering I have to go have
a heart search
so I have to leave now we're gonna have
to cut this did I tell you that I'm
having a quadruple bypass today yeah
no no I'm also having uh both eyes
removed and uh that's a whole other
thing that's happening yeah if you watch
OG Star Wars somewhere yeah my house
does uh I can come over does Lucas does
Lucas also does he have a hit squad out
trying to find people like you who can
sing the song and just and and kill you
because he probably wants it all erased
from people's minds I don't think he
cares anymore because he sold the whole
thing I think he's oh he's still here no
he still can't well good question uh I
don't know but I've got those
de-specialized editions they're called
and high def if the two of you want to
come over we could have a slumber party
we could giggle we could tickle each
other we can borrow them yeah or I could
say I'm gonna come by and borrow them
and just if you don't hear from me it
means I'm coming soon no no these are
these are not physical media these are
digital they're on a drive so we have to
watch them at my house
yeah yeah we do a knife which I can't go
we watch all three movies I can't be
there I'm having my entire pelvis
removed next year so there won't be a
chill Chumps next year yeah it's being
it's being replaced with a just an old
wicker basket yeah and I gotta drive him
you gotta drive him I gotta drive and
you gotta drive me home alone and no
speed bumps because I'll have no ass on
the way oh come along and we'll get
those little DVD players for the
backgrounds now all right take it easy
yeah it's been said I don't have much of
an ass
it's a two-minute surgery okay all right
okay okay that's nice I don't think
people have to know just how bad it is
back there
you don't think people have to you've
been on television for like 30 years I
know but usually my ass was covered or
if the monologue the ass was facing the
other way and then the the things on one
episode of the show so you know but I
stuff I put stuff back there I put two
uh two two irons to do iron clothes with
back there
I have these two bulbous trunks would
you shut the up what you're out of
control you're out of control you I let
you sing the whole jab jub glub glove
song you got the words wrong I think I
got him right I'm gonna this has to stop
this has to stop now what we took away
from this episode yeah is that
um by episode you mean mental episode
the episode I just had yeah where you
sang the glub Club song then Sona went
on this why just crazy take that I have
a flat ass
which is just not true super hot take
yeah and super hot ass thank you big
daddy
come on man I like an asset you can hose
down and that no water stays on it it
just immediately incredible you know all
right yeah yeah oh it's incredible it
splashes back yeah
what are you doing what are you
muttering I'm singing the Jabba's Palace
song the original one that they took out
oh no I did I really wanted to hear it
did you yeah you know what I have to
move on because we have an amazing guest
today I think they can hang on wait a
minute Our Guest has a Star Wars
connection that's right yes Qui-Gon Jinn
green lightsaber I was gonna say that
yeah we were all gonna just about to say
that and then I remembered that I was
educated all right here we go